[Music]
whooping join the cruise I was left at
the altar a few days ago and my dad who
I haven't seen since I was 5 showed up
to my wedding unannounced the two of us
got incredibly drunk that night and I
must have blacked out because
hi sweetheart oh [ __ ] somehow I dragged
him onto this cruise that was supposed
to be my honeymoon your honeymoon suite
congratulation hey that's my dad I'll be
back in the office on Thursday I'm
leaving early
because I don't need a vacation Rachel
earth to Rachel Rachel how are you fine
[Music]
are you gonna go on pretending you're
still fine with what happened the other
day she hates me frankly I can't blame
her I've been a therapist now for four
months so I want to give you my
professional opinion for free it's all
your fault
thank you
I did not wanna end up alone dear
loneliness is a very powerful thing
[Music]
you're better without me there
[Music]
why are you here after all this time why
not
14 richly racial it's not hairy
you're insane thank you yeah great oh
yeah good hang
[Music]